and we continue our team coverage now
with sasha loftus she joins us now live
along the red carpet at the music cares
gala at the mgm grand bar ballroom and
sasha this event is actually raising
money for the music community in times
of need right
it is denise this is obviously the
biggest night of the year for the music
cares charity we have a lot of big names
big faces here we're actually joined by
billy ray cyrus hello
big night big night i'm good thank you
and big night for music and really ahead
of the grammys here in las vegas it's
great great to be here to honor jonathan
mitchell at music cares and great to be
back in vegas i was
telling somebody earlier the last show i
did before america shut down
here in vegas a tribute to neil diamond
neil diamond was there
all about the cleveland clinic and
raising money for them and
i left out of here flew out the next
morning went to tennessee and
it seemed like the whole world shut down
so for me this is going full circle and
a new beginning and no better way to do
it than right here in las vegas honoring
joni mitchell great city and you
actually dropped a new song today as
well right i did yeah me and snoop dogg
avila brothers we've got a song called
hard-working man
dj quick mix that did a great job
so got off to a great start today it's
again it's a tip of the hat to the men
and women that work so hard to keep this
country going
we put some positive food for thought in
there for
kids who have dreams about working hard
and takes elbow grease and
you know most of all listen to mama you
know what mama says is probably that's
what you ought to do and that's though
the song's called hard-working man it's
about taking advice from mama and mama
says work hard don't give up
perfectly said and thank you so much for
joining us here welcome to las vegas
we're glad to have you honored to be
with you have a great night thank you so
he has lots of big people here tonight
we're expecting a lot of other big faces
that you'll probably recognize we saw
joni mitchell brandi carlisle rita
wilson who is actually on the board of
directors here so we of course will be
here all night on the red carpet
bringing you the very latest ahead of
sunday's grammys right here in las vegas
reporting live sasha loftis live local
now